we're very lucky to have enjoyed us good
job from UC San Diego and he'll talk
about labeling it okay thank you so I'm
I'm gonna be talking about some variants
of the active learning problem and just
to introduce this so what one thing
that's worth pointing out is you know
the field of machine learning there's a
whole lot of different things
clustering embedding density estimation
you know the list goes on but it really
seems that you know at least at this
point in time the one thing that it does
really really well is learning accurate
classifiers from very large data sets
okay that is the sort of the the
strongest strongest thing it does and
unfortunately getting very large label
data sets is often not easy okay so so
this is motivated the field of active
learning it's this realization that in
many problems the common situation is
that you have a lot of unlabeled data
but the labels are hard to come by okay
so if you're a marine biologist trying
to classify dolphin clicks you have some
underwater microphone that can record
hours and hours okay but then some
expert has to listen to these recordings
and classify clicks according to the
species of dolphin they're from okay if
you are doing computational drug design
you can come up with vast amounts of
unlabeled data
okay libraries of virtual chemical
compounds but if you want to label one
of these points if you want to figure
out whether it binds to a target of
interest a wet lab experiment has to be
done okay so there are all these
situations where you can get all the
unlabeled data you want but labeling it
is very expensive okay and so the model
over here is that you had a lot of
unlabeled data you don't know anything's
labeled you want to have nonetheless
learn a classifier from some pre
specified class age
and you only really have enough
resources to get a few labels and so the
way to do this is adaptively you ask for
one of the labels you wait to find out
what it is then you ask for another one
you wait to find out what it is and in
this way you try and always pick the
thing that you feel is gonna be
maximally informative and so the
question is what are good querying
schemes and you know what is the
trade-off between the accuracy of the
classifier you get in the number of
labels you ask for okay so this is the
set up in active learning and what I'm
gonna do is to just talk about some of
the work that's been done in this area
there's a huge amount of work that's
been done both on the practice and on
the theory side and I'll talk about it
for about 5 minutes sort or 10 minutes
and then and I think it'll then turn out
that there's actually a fundamental flaw
in this in this problem formulation and
so I'll move to sort of a an alternative
formulation that's sort of much better
suited to to sort of you know the way
machine learning is actually done and
then that'll be the focus of the talk so
active learning so so what are the
schemes out there has been studied very
thoroughly in both theory and practice
and unfortunately there's a gap between
the two the sort of schemes that are
used in practice are somewhat different
in in flavor even at a very high level
from the ones that the theoreticians had
come up with okay so what are the
practical schemes okay so this is the
way they look you let's say you're
learning linear classifiers say okay
that active learning scheme for just
about any class of interest okay let's
see doing linear classifiers you you you
have a whole bunch of unlabeled points
you've seen a few labeled so far you fit
a linear classifier to the points you've
seen and then you say oh you know what's
the points near the boundary those are
the ones I'm uncertain about let me ask
for one of those labels we ask for the
label of the point near the boundary or
sometimes it's more sophisticated and
you say well these are the points I'm
uncertain about the points near the
boundary let me ask for a label
that is likely to reduce the uncertainty
on these points okay but the high level
idea is that you're committing to a
particular classifier and you're using
it to assess what the uncertain points
are and what was it these are the
practical schemes they have a whole
bunch of methods that are rather
different in flavor the theoreticians
have come up with and what what happens
over here is that instead of committing
to a specific classifier you just say
that based on the labels i've seen so
far this is the set of candidate
classifiers the label based on the
labels I've seen so far these are the
plausible linear separators at a high
will pink of an uncertain point as being
a point on which the set of linear
separators has some disagreement has a
significant amount of disagreement so
does that make sense and so feel free to
to stop me anytime okay so the very
different sorts of schemes and and you
know unfortunately a pretty big gap yeah
pretty large like the version space is
very large so it seems like doing this
explicitly would be completely
intractable in the case of linear
separators you know it's an infinite
space but people have cooked up very
clever ways of doing this implicitly by
just storing the list of label points in
so far you can then ask questions about
the version space how much uncertainty
is there on this particular point you
don't actually have to explicitly
[Music]
okay so so how bad are these practical
schemes I know I said what is the
problem is it that they you know they
don't give you optimal rates of
conversions they don't they aren't
really choosing the maximally
informative points so it turns out that
in general they're actually much much
worse than that I mean forget about
getting the right answer with just a few
labels they do not necessarily get the
right answer even with infinitely many
labels so they're not statistically
consistent and I'll show you I'll show
you why that is okay so this is some
this is a standard active learning
heuristic where you choose a few points
at random you get the lay of the land
you choose your current boundary and
then each query points near the market
okay so let's say the data lies in one
dimension so we choose a few points at
random
maybe we beget some points from this
cluster that contains 45% of the data
some points from this cluster that
contains 45% of the data so our initial
boundary will be somewhere in the middle
okay and so the UH the points we
consider uncertain will be points um
somewhere in the middle and so we'll end
up asking a lot of queries over here and
as we ask more and more queries we will
converge to this boundary
this is the optimal boundary well let's
see this boundary has got a five percent
error rate there as this other boundary
over here has only a 2.5 percent error
rate okay so this is a situation where
it's not even statistically consistent
even in the limit of having infinitely
many labels it converges to two to a bad
solution and so this is this is sort of
this lack of consistency is the problem
that has dogged active learning this
because you're choosing your optimum not
based you're not using the fact that you
have a lot of other samples just
unlabeled shouldn't be using using those
to use your code to find the right next
classifier right so it's not it's not
making proper use of the data
distribution right of the unlabeled data
distribution and so also I'm gonna be
mentioning a lot of open problems
because you know although there's some
work been done in this area I would say
that it's largely open and one of them
is really to find a generic fix to these
kinds of heuristics so we have these
uncertainty based heuristics is there a
way to augment them with some random
sampling and perhaps rewriting that will
at least make them statistically
consistent okay forget about you know
you know forget about being optimal in
terms of the number of labels okay so
that's that's an open problem and it's
uh you know people have thought about it
but it's it's tricky okay so so that's
one open so so these are sort of the
practical schemes and and sort of
generic failings why it's not being
possible to prove things about it even
the most basic property is failed by you
know it it's failed by these methods but
is it true that in this case you can't
get any guaranteed probably you know you
can argue that those two gets that you
won't get the optimal error but maybe
you'll get it most twice the optimal
letter or something like that so what's
happening in this case is that at some
point in time you have found the
boundary okay and that's your current
boundary and there's a cluster of points
far away from the boundary and you
never ask any questions about that
cluster because it's far away from the
boundary you're sure all of those are
sports documents but actually the
politics okay and this can be
arbitrarily bad like this could be it
really depends on how big that cluster
race
okay so so so what are the sort of
methods that pure additions have cooked
up look like okay so so let's again
stick to this case of one dimensional
data where the data lies on the line
each classifier is the threshold on one
side is plus the other side is minus
this has the VC dimension of one we know
that in order to learn a classifier with
error epsilon error at most Epsilon in
regular supervised learning we need one
over epsilon label points okay what
error one over a million we need a
million labeled points now for active
learning what we would do is we start
with those million unlabeled points and
we just asked for the label in the
middle and it turns out that back to
plus then we know the boundary has to
lie on that side and so then we ask for
the 25% of a point and so on okay and in
this way the number of labels we need is
just log 1 over Epsilon
okay so we're literally down from a
million to log of a million so what what
this scheme is doing is that it's not
committing to any classifier any given
point in time it's just maintaining the
version space by saying initially the
boundary could be anywhere
now I've limited to this much not
limited to this much and in this
particular case it's able to shrink the
version space in half literally each
time okay so that's how it works of
course this is just four points on the
line but over the years over the past
decade or so people have extended this
idea to many other hypothesis classes of
interest
okay linear separators and D dimensional
space all sorts of different classes
okay and for these other classes it's
not necessarily the case that each query
will have the version space you know
sometimes the the amount you cut off the
version space with each query is a
little bit smaller but still in general
there is this exponential shrinkage
where the dependence on one over epsilon
you know very often shrinks to log 1
over Epsilon so okay and so there are
many different algorithms of its time so
this is sort of the state of active
learning and as I said unfortunately
there's a basic problem with this whole
model and so let me let me just explain
what that is it's the following ok so
let's say you get this new data set and
you're in this situation you have a
million points you can only afford to
label a few of them but you want to
build a classifier so you say ok I'm
going to build a linear classifier let
me find the best active learning
algorithm for linear classifiers to get
me out with them you know it's a super
you know it's super careful about which
points it picks you pick a thousand
points and you get a linear classifier
that you are assured it's close to the
best linear classifier to get this
linear classifier you're gratified and
then after playing around with it a
little bit you realize that it's
actually got ten percent error you know
that you can't really do much better as
far as linear classifiers go but at this
point you decide you know what I think I
actually need a quadratic support vector
machine so then you pull out the active
learning algorithm for quadratic support
vector machines and you start running
that and that also asks for a thousand
labels but those house and labels are
different because all of these
algorithms are fine-tuned to specific
hypothesis classes so it asks for a
different thousand points and then you
get the quadratic boundary and then you
realize oh actually I needed a thing I
need a lunar own net let me find the
best active learning algorithm for
neural nets and then they say well you
know actually the best active learning
depends on whether you want one layer or
two layers there are three layers and
how many nodes there are in each layer
and so this goes on and on and so this
procedure is really not I mean this
problem formulation is not compatible
with a kind of typical way in which
classified development takes place where
there's this kind of a these iterations
in which you know different models are
tried ok and so what I would like to
suggest is a variant of the problem that
you can call active annotation and here
the final product is not a classifier
but a full label dataset okay so you you
start with your collection of unlabeled
points
you don't know anything's label you
provide some parameters epsilon and
Delta and there's a human expert who can
answer who can answer any query now the
algorithm begins it asks for also a tax
all sorts of questions but at the end it
has to produce a fully label data set so
it asks for some labels and it fills the
rest in by itself right so there are
there are some models in which the human
expert is allowed to be noisy and so you
know there are there are different noise
models one thing that so so if you look
at the completely noiseless case a lot
of those results extend very easily to
the two to give a bit benign forms of
noise there on any given instance there
is a certain probability of giving the
right answer and a certain probability
giving the wrong answer and the probably
giving the right answer is greater than
the probability of giving any particular
wrong answer if there are several
choices for what
this probability of error yes yeah right
so that's the sort of noise model that
is generically easier to handle and as
far as labeling goes so does the problem
formulation make sense
you give me the epsilon-delta the the
algorithm asks a few as as some queries
fills in the rest and the guarantee it
has to give on the data set is that now
with probability one minus Delta over
the internal randomness of the algorithm
the data set is sort of epsilon pure at
most an epsilon fraction of the labels
are warm okay and of course you want to
minimize the calls to the human expert
in producing this so once your the data
set of this kind then you can you know
try all sorts of different types of
models on it okay that makes sense right
the you are you're forced to label the
entire data set right but a priori you
have no idea whether you would get an
epsilon property and so and and what
we'll see that is that method for
solving this problem tend to be fairly
flexible in the kind you still have the
same sort of input on this and you want
the generalization error isn't that
related to the sort of house yeah and
the active learning setting all you can
guarantee is that you're at most Epsilon
worse than the bethe linear classifier
say oh where is here you're forced to
label that you're forced to produce a
good day that's it
one profession just to follow up on that
question what if you were you fix it
hypothesis class and once the version
space is below
epsilon about you decide okay I pick
whatever hypothesis is left label
everything and then use that as your
labeling so with some high probability
you are you would have labeled with a
very crisp epsilon yeah so if you start
with the particular versions which you
start with a particular hypothesis class
and you get lucky in the sense in the
sense that there is some hypothesis in
that class that is fairly good on the
data then you can just use an active
learning algorithm for that
okay so I'm gonna talk about the work
that's been done on this and some of the
methods I will discuss are from the
early 2000s some of them are very recent
from this year okay it's going to be
basically focused on the open problem
since much more is open than known okay
and yeah this light you just set up this
the way you think it's the right way of
doing it and the other ways are wrong
yes
so the baddest that is correct
and but but later I will introduce an
even more general version of this
problem where the feedback from the
auricle consists not just of labels but
of richer of richer information as well
and this is a sort of a very exciting
area of research ok so we have the
active annotation problem and I'll talk
basically methods over here there are
two broad classes of methods that have
been pretty successful both on the
theory and practical side graph based
methods and cluster based method and so
I'll spend a little bit of time talking
about these so how would you even solve
this problem okay so here's a really
simple baseline so you have this data
set you're forced to label all of it why
not do this pick a few points at random
get the labels and fill in the rest
using nearest neighbor okay so you get
labels for a thousand points you
actually have a million minus the
thousand remaining on label points and
for each of them you look at its nearest
neighbor amongst those thousand anything
that's fairly reasonable okay what's
wrong okay so so how can we improve upon
this the first is to do more intelligent
query okay instead of picking a thousand
of those points at random you could
maybe pick a thousand of them that are
spread out in some way
the second is that methods like nearest
neighbor you know nonparametric methods
of this form you know don't have great
rates in high dimension okay and so
ideally what one would like is something
that is more adaptive to underlying
structure in data for example cluster
structure or manifold structure okay so
for example if the data looks like this
and these are the two labels you've got
then and you want to figure out the
label for this maybe you should look at
the manifold structure rather than
looking at the new risk so there is a
very nice algorithm that incorporates
all of these ideas is has been reared by
all accounts rather successful in
practice and for which sadly that theory
is not developed at all so I'll tell you
what it is very simple and nice method
this is due to Jerry's use Zubin karmani
and John Lafferty okay that is from back
in 2003 okay so it's been 15 years
people still haven't figured out exactly
how to say you know how how to say good
things about this it's a it's a very
nice method okay so here's here's what
happens
you've got your end data points you
build a neighborhood graph on them okay
so you connect each point to its get
nearest neighbor is something like that
this is basically adapted to manifold
structure so you know because because
the the nearest neighbors in Euclidean
space are roughly speaking also the
nearest neighbors on the manifold okay
that's the if you look at look if you
look at local regions Euclidean and
manifold are basically the same and so
that's the intuition behind these
neighborhood
so you do this and now let's say that
you get a few labels
how would you fill in the rest so you
find out that this is 1 this is 0 this
one is 0
how would you fill in the remaining
labels and what they suggest is to do it
by solving a very simple optimization
problem so they said okay let's
introduce a variable for each label this
is going to be F 1 this is going to be F
2 this is going to be F 6 now the labels
we know we're going to constrain so F 9
has to be equal to 1 F 8 has to be equal
to 0 and so on and everything else can
be any real value it doesn't even have
to be 0 or 1 okay
it's be any real value subject to
minimizing this this smoothness cost
function we just want it to be the case
that neighboring points are unlikely to
have different labels okay so we charge
a penalty when neighboring points have
different labels yeah basically solving
a linear system constrained to those
points right it's just a least squares
problem okay so this is the least
squares problem it's got a nice closed
form solution okay and it's it's not
hard to see that in fact all the numbers
that it fills in are going to be between
0 & 1 so you solve it and it's going to
give you numbers like this and then to
actually classify you threshold you
could threshold this at 1/2 but they're
actually other there are other variants
you know if the classes are imbalanced
you want you would want to threshold in
a slightly different way okay so so this
how you would fill in the labels and it
turns out that these numbers have a nice
interpretation in terms of random walks
okay there's something that's easy to
check basically what is this point 7
mean well suppose you would have started
random walk at that node where you
choose a neighbor at random and you go
over there and you keep you keep going
until you hit a label turned 27 means
that you have a point 7 probability that
the label point you end up with is a 1
and so over here there's only 0.1
probability that you would end up with
with with a 1 right so that's yeah so
this is just so that we will get to that
in a second yeah so how do we choose
these points right because I'm asked
with any active learning scheme it's
gonna be adaptive so we're gonna use
these numbers to then figure out which
one to pick next okay okay so so this is
the this is the the overall setup yep so
in fact it doesn't boil down do you want
to cut were you basically the ones and
zeroes are separated and you're
minimizing the number of edges that are
cut or maybe the conductance exactly yes
so it is minimizing some sort of
continuous approximation to cuts it's
yes it's something like that
right so okay so but what's the active
learning scheme so now we know that we
have a few labels we know how we're
gonna fill it in okay so what's the
active learning scheme well at this
point in time let's let's quantify the
overall uncertainty and we'll say the
uncertainty in here is zero because we
know the label the uncertainty for this
one is a point one the uncertainty for
this one is a point three the answer
need for this one is a point four and we
add up all those uncertainties and that
tells us the uncertainty of our current
configuration
okay now the way we decide what we're
going to query is the following okay we
say okay well what would be the benefit
of querying say this one well we don't
know what its label is going to turn out
to be but we think it's got a 70% chance
of being a one and a 30% chance of being
a zero let's say it turns out to be a
one let's resolve the linear system with
the one over here and see what
uncertainty ensues and let's resolve the
linear system with a zero in here and
see what uncertainty we get and then we
weight that by 0.7 and 0.3 and that
tells us how the uncertainty will change
in expectation if we label that point
okay and and so this is how it proceed
so I sort of greedily try to reduce the
uncertainty as far
as possible very nice algorithm very
intuitive and as I said you know by all
accounts it seems to work well so how
can we prove about it can we show that
it you know has good rates of
convergence so no unfortunately is not
even consistent okay it's just running
into the same problem again okay
and so so why is that well let's say we
have three labels okay how what what
values would you fill in for the rest
well over here if you would have thought
a random walk here you would hit a 1
with probability 1 so it would fill in
ones over here okay and so the values
that would fill in over here are 0.5
point two five point seven five those
are the random walk probabilities and
over here would fill in ones which means
it would never query any of these points
because it's completely certain right
yeah yeah so there is so okay so there
right so yeah so they're different
notions of uncertainty one can come up
with right and the problem is that when
you have a limited number of labels any
notion of uncertainty you come up with
is gonna be you know way off okay it's
it's in fact harder to estimate
uncertainty than it is to estimate
labels okay so these uncertainty
estimates are going to be very
inaccurate and the only thing you can
hope is that as time goes on and you get
more labels the uncertainty estimates
actually get better okay and so the
question is is there a way to modify
these schemes that take into account the
they take this into account
doesn't somehow Epsilon random helps
like in getting away with all the so
there's always an epsilon property of
randomly picking an element and having a
level yeah so that so so that's that's a
good question so the coins like you know
if we were to you know basically every
few steps just pick one at random right
just pick a label at random would that
solve the problem and and that's not
know so that's yeah so one very nice
open problem over here is is just to fix
this okay this is the lovely algorithm
it's intuitive you know but it's not
even consistent okay there it really
feels like there's something you can do
that's fairly close to this in spirit
that will be consistent and will you
know and will have reasonable rates and
what is that okay people left what about
this and I will give you I'll show you
one of the things that that that was
suggested and it's very different in
spirit from this out
or something from the squares
right yeah so the distribution over here
is basically a kind of Gaussian random
field because these things are allowed
to be continuous so one can sample from
that and there is a version of this that
does that and it's not clear whether
that nothing is known at all yeah
actually this yeah links to that graph
so again making the graph a little more
dense well I mean something density
shoots about random like now you have
the path if you have let's say a random
arching between the vertices it's gonna
become three regular you have surplus so
this this cut structure will cease to
exist
maybe yeah yeah so that would be
interesting if that if there was a way
to do that that both maintain the
benefits of having a neighborhood graph
which is the preservation of this local
structure and yeah okay so this is one
open problem so yeah so as I said this
algorithm was for 15 years ago but two
years ago a group of people came up with
finally a suggestion for an algorithm
like this which which does have some
nice properties and so I'll tell you
I'll tell you what that is and this is
by Gotham dasar T Rob Nowak and Jerry
Schue okay
and there's also a graph based algorithm
and it has a very and this you know this
this has nice rates of convergence and
guarantees and so on we'll see in a
second okay so um so what is this
algorithm doing ok so again you build a
neighborhood graph over here the graph
happens to be just at this 2d lattice
okay
these are the edges and let's say that
we have the ones in the middle and the
zeros outside those are the two classes
what this method is trying to do is to
identify all the cut edges the edges
that cross between the two classes okay
so the goal of the method is to identify
all of these edges
that's what it's trying to do and it
thinks that that is its goal it wants to
get to that goal as fast as possible
once you think of things that way a
whole lot of fairly intuitive methods
suggest themselves if you want to find
cut edges okay why don't do something
like this initially you don't know where
the zeros are ones up but randomly
example a few points until you get at
least a zero in a one and now you know
they're on any path connecting those two
you have a cottage so you can kind of do
a binary search on that path and very
quickly locate one of the cottages and
if there's another path you can do a
binary search on that path and locate
the number of cottages and this way it
seems that you know if you're not
thinking apart from the random sampling
you're literally the time it takes to
locate each cottage is just binary
search on a path it's like log the
diameter of the graph something like
that okay so it seems like like you you
you you know a method like this would
have a label complexity that depends on
the number of cut edges the log the
diameter of the graph and in order for
this random sampling to work you know
you what also matters is the proportion
of each class and in fact and you know
it's it's sort of clear that this is
both you know that Dean you know
something like this would be sufficient
so let me tell you what the method it's
a very nice method okay so so what it
does is it starts with this and then it
keeps you know whenever it's stuck for
any asset
whenever it's stuck it does random
sampling okay and whenever it has two
points of opposite polarity that are
connected it looks for the shortest path
between two points of this type and
queries the midpoint of that path okay
so let's say that it starts by querying
these these three so it lets say it
starts by querying this point over here
it's a zero okay
next query is that point that's another
zero and then it queried this point it's
a one okay finally we have two points of
opposite polarity now let's look at all
shortest paths between points of
opposite polarity
this one part over here or that very
long but this is the shortest path over
here okay or actually there's several
shortest paths and let's query the
midpoint of that shortest path okay so
it queries the midpoint it gets this
point over here and it finds that that's
a zero okay now again it looks at all
shortest paths between points of
opposite polarity and now the shortest
path is just this so it queries the
midpoint of that bug okay so it's going
to query this one next and now it is
located a cottage okay it's found this
cottage and it's just going to remove it
from the graph so it's found this
cottage it's going to remove it and now
again it looks at shortest points
between all points or all pairs of
opposite polarity and it's going to
query that one and find another and find
another cut edge very nice algorithm
right so so what were they able to show
well I think it's you know the sort of
the kind of bound they get is exactly
the sort of bound I was outlining
earlier that there's a certain charge
for random sampling and then basically
it's the number of cottages times the
log diameter of the graph okay the case
they look at is where there are K nodes
adjacent to cut edges and if you better
remove the cut edges you might not get
just two connected components you could
have several connected components and so
it matters how many there are let's say
that M connected components and they
each have side beta times n they each
are fairly large and the diameter graph
is Delta then this is the number of
queries you end up making
so so the question is what is this
translate to in terms of statistical
rates of convergence is this truly
sublinear
and that's also something they work out
and and this is what they find okay so
if you would have just do passive
learning nonparametric learning in d
dimensional space the error rate looks
under a smoothness condition say the
function you're learning is Lipschitz
looks like n to the minus 1 over D
that's really bad when D is large what
that means is if you want error epsilon
you need about 1 over epsilon to the
deep ones and I mean I can briefly
indicate why that's the case you know if
you have if you have you know if your
domain looks like this let's just say
we're into D okay so let's say we're in
high dimension and and all you know is
that the function you're learning is
Lipschitz and you want error epsilon
well basically you have to create this
grid of size Epsilon okay you've got to
create this grid and you need maybe a
couple of points inside each grid box
okay and so and so and and that's why
you get you need n to be about 1 over
epsilon to the B if all you know is
something is Lipschitz so that's sort of
necessary and sufficient and and what
these people are saying is that is that
they get something that's a little bit
better okay and so and then so let me
let me explain what this is so what they
do is they say we're gonna have a
smoothness condition on the boundary
we're gonna think of the boundary as
being not a D dimensional object but
basically a D minus 1 dimensional object
okay so
you know in in the 2d setting you could
have a crazy decision boundary that sort
of fills up the whole space right but
what they're saying is no if you were to
divide if you were to create a grid then
the boundary intersects only a small
number of cells of this grid and and so
so in the Kenda in the 2d case if you
have n cells it'll intersect about
square root n of them in 3d it'll be n
to the 2/3 and in general it'll be n to
the minus 1 over D and we know that this
met her the number of queries it asks is
literally going to be proportional to
the number of boundary cells ignoring
logarithmic factor the log diameter and
so you do get something that is sub
linear but but only very slightly ok so
instead of n u n to the 1 minus instead
of querying all endpoints it queries
into though 1 minus 1 over D ok so what
can you so this this 2 sub linear it's
good there are you know you know you can
show that you can't do any better than
this but obviously this is not good news
in the sense that you know one would
like to query much less than this and
what are what could one do you know
because if the dimensions high like a
thousand or or 10,000 then
yeah nonparametric setting you can't
beat this because that could be the cut
size right and they are outputting in
the cut explicitly so unless you make
some assumptions on what the function is
you really can't beat this so is the is
like assuming the data is uniform over 0
1 to the D the right thing to think
about should I mean you started with
these these nine uniform data sets and
this is what motivated like a lot of
this work I mean it seemed like this is
the wrong st. to be analyzing I mean
right right so right so yeah assuming
the data distribution is uniform with 0
1 to D that's crazy right but but it
turns out that the bounds are you know
you know if you wanted to instead assume
that the data distribution is simply
bounded below in this bounded away from
0 in this the same ranging you can you
get something similar but if you start
by what with the graph is is the nearest
neighbor graph on a data set in a high
dimension where the degree is K which is
much smaller than
mentioned do you use e-cigarettes the
pendulum okay and said D well so the
sort of thing that you can hope for is
if you say that right it it's this you
know so having a data distribution
uniform of a zero one to delete means
that the data fills up the space you
know so they a different assumption is
that the data lies on a low dimensional
manifold or that the data lies in a set
of low doubling dimension and if that's
the case then you can get the same rate
where this is replaced by the doubling
dimension and and in fact we'll see that
very soon for a different method okay so
that's that's one thing you can hope for
it's one kind of structure that you can
hope to be adapted to and it's been and
you know that they've been a lot of
bounds proved of this kind simply
because we have these nice formalisms
like doubling dimension but there are
other types of structure that we would
like to capture like cluster structure
and so on so which we don't have these
sort of nice indices and that would be
interesting right it was some sort of a
generic reduction of that
[Music]
so certainly you know in the manifold
case it's known that if you have data
that's in a so this is something that
Clarkson showed following wake in a few
years earlier that eunuch data lies on a
k-dimensional manifold and even a random
projection to K over epsilon squared
dimensions preserves all distances
within 1 plus or minus epsilon as long
as the manifolds curvature is bounded ok
so this says so these are the positive
results okay and and and this method is
very different in spirit from the other
one and unfortunately in practice
doesn't work as well ok and what is that
you know it is because it's actually
very clever it doesn't seem to be losing
out a lot you know it seems very
optimized and the problem is that it's
optimized to find all cut edges in the
shortest time possible that's what it's
trying to do so if that was the task you
were if that was the task then it's
perfect for that okay but what usually
happens is that you stop the process
long before you found all the cut edges
you know you aren't able to and this
does not gracefully decay along the
other along the way where is the rival
method is greedily trying to reduce the
uncertainty on every single step and
therefore you know you know so and
therefore is looking better along the
way in some sense ok and so it would be
very nice to to just somehow fix this
you know this is just yet another case
where you know active learning theory
and practice have got this that this
white divide between them just to
understand the question better is it
that in general you really don't care
about the cut you really care about the
error in classification so let's say the
cut was a little wavy and you just said
it was straight that's probably still
good enough okay so is that that's that
that one issue and you know the other
thing is
is that you know you can expect two to
stop long before you're able to to get
the cut and so like how would you huh
you know what could you do in
anticipation of that
okay so cluster based methods have also
been you know what's quite successful in
active learning and here the period
practice that perhaps a little bit
closer okay and these methods are just
childishly simple so this was a method
that I suggested with Daniel Hsu about
ten years ago and by that time I have
been doing a quite a lot of work on
active learning coming up with some very
sophisticated and clever algorithms I
was very proud of and this just almost
seemed like a joke in comparison because
it was like so simple and obvious and I
think this is the only one that people
have ever used
if you only want anybody ever asked
about or you know like what's the code
for or you know and so so yeah I mean I
tell you a little bit about it so the
the idea is just ridiculous okay so
lucky hey you know let's say the data
looks like it's got five clusters maybe
we only need five labels one label per
cluster and we're done okay so that's
the starting point okay okay now
obviously we need to be able to adapt to
any data so you know maybe the cluster
structure will not be so clearly defined
maybe the clusters are not pure we have
to we you know we have to be sort of
mindful of that so let's do things this
way we had the unlabeled data set let's
start by clustering it maybe we get two
clusters and now here's the key thing we
are going to randomly sample a few
points within each cluster we're not
allowed to say I want a class for that
label we're just allowed to say give me
three random points of this cluster okay
so we choose a few points at random and
we get their labels
and now this looks pretty pure and so
I'm feeling good in a pinch I would just
label the whole thing red and be not
worried about it okay but this is not
looking pure so what do I do
they cluster eat some more I I further
partition it
and now what has happened is that
because I had chosen these points at
random because there are random points
in here they're all so random within
these clusters and so I can reuse the
labels that's it
that's all that's going on right and you
can just keep doing this and so one way
to think about it is you start with a
hierarchy you start with a hierarchy you
pick a few points at random over there
you sample their labels and if it's not
pure then you move down to the next
level and now you look here and if
that's pure that's fine otherwise over
here you move down to the next level
very simple okay where they are
yeah so here though so this is a very
simplistic scheme where the clustering
is just done in advance the hierarchy is
built in advance so so yeah how do you
build a hierarchy how do you decide at
any given point that several clusters
where you could pick a pick a query
which one you pick and how do you decide
when a cluster is sufficiently impure
that you would move to its move to its
child okay so two versions of this
scheme or maybe some more banana lized
in our earliest paper we just made you
know the simplest choices just said what
hierarchical clustering do you use well
let's just use the most popular
hierarchical story algorithm Ward's
method which cluster should be query the
one that's the least pure why not okay
and when do you move down when
confidence intervals indicate that the
cluster is highly impure okay later work
by root owner Sharon wolf Shai Ben David
and samuri / - faith looked at well were
able to give nice generalization bounds
for this and for example one of the
things they did was to not just have any
old clustering algorithm but they said
okay let's let's come up with a tree
structure that is provably adapted to do
structuring the data so for example it's
known that if you have a random
projection
which is kind of like a KD tree but at
each given point you pick a direction at
random and you split and you build a
tree in this way it is adaptive to the
doubling dimension of the data okay and
so you know and then and so on and for
that they were able to get rates that
would look roughly like this but with
the doubling dimension in place so so
this is a scheme where yeah I'm not
going to go into the experiment you know
it basically seems to work fairly well I
think the open problem over here is is
yeah is to come up with the right
decision for what to cluster and when to
move down and that's just not been
figured out okay so there's a root and
optimizing that would make a huge
difference in practice as well so even
though the sort of silly random initial
choices that we may end up doing fairly
well and an optimizing that could make a
very very large difference okay so so
that's an open problem over there okay
so in the few minutes that I have left I
just wanted to talk about something that
you know we're working on much more
recently and it's a very interesting
area these days and that is to move
beyond labels okay so you know machine
learning systems for the most part have
relied only on labels all we ever give
them as labels pluses and minuses and
all they ever give us back is a
classifier that gives labels and you
know all of a sudden there's a interest
in making things having the interaction
be a little bit richer where we don't
just label stuff but give simple
explanations and in return the
classifier also returns the simple
explanation so how would this play into
the annotation problem so here's an
example okay so the expert is asked to
annotate a document and looks at the
document and says that sports in
addition
since it since the human has read the
document he also highlights a couple of
words like a wicked keeper there are
highly indicative of the document maple
or a computer vision system gets the
latest photo uploaded by a birdwatcher
and says oh look at that that's a canary
and then the human expert says no it's
not it's a Warbler but at the same time
provides a little bit of an explanation
by saying clicking on the beak or
something that distinguishes these two
these two types of birds okay so these
are both cases in which the laborer is
doing a little bit more work and
providing some information that's
potentially ambiguous okay so over here
it's providing a word like wicket keeper
over here it's clicking on the beak and
it's like what does that mean is that is
that the color of the beak is it the
fact that there is a beak was he
actually clicking on the head and did
the beak by mistake you know it's
ambiguous but it seems like it could be
super helpful okay and so it's of
interest to sort of formalize this and
see how this helps with annotating
datasets quickly and and so the work
over here deals with formalizing the
semantics of this kind of feedback
quantifying rates of convergence with
feedback and to be honest it just
reshaped the landscape of what is
learnable so for example one thing that
we're gonna show in in the conference
later this year is that you can learn
disjunctive normal form formulas with
this kind of feedback over here okay so
this is a type of formula that Valiant
you know started talking about in his
original pac---- learning paper because
he thought it was something that's very
natural for humans it's a very natural
way for us to express concept and here
it turned out to be hard to learn but
once you allow a few explanations then
it becomes much easier to learn okay so
so let me just finish with a
with a modification of the of the
annotation problem okay so this was the
original annotation problem that we have
an unlabeled data set of end points and
we were able to query individual labels
a modified problem is that either a
human or you know or some other system
has also given us a collection of week
rules okay these rules might be things
like oh if it contains the wicked with
the word wicketkeeper it means it sports
okay that's an example of a week rule
and these rules don't apply to every
instance this only applies to documents
with the word wicketkeeper it's a week
predictor sometimes it's wrong okay so
it's a week rule but we have a
collection of week rules like this and
you know so for example each week rule
could even be a crowdsourced worker a
workers that occasionally abstain and
when it doesn't abstain makes a
prediction that sometimes wrong how can
we use these to rapidly label a data set
and currently the system so for example
there's a system by a chris ray at hand
but called snorkel this very popular
that basically allows people to specify
week rules and you know for any given
document or instance there are many
rules that potentially apply to it's
saying possibly conflicting things how
does one resolve HUD's one resolve this
and they just have an ad hoc way of
doing this and you'll be very nice to
kind of work this out more carefully you
can think of this as a generalization of
the crowdsourcing problem there also
applies to annotation
okay so I won't go into more work on
this so yes I think some interesting
open problems are on the graph based
annotation side too
just look at the juga Romani Lafferty
algorithm and figure out what needs to
be done to it to make it good you know
to make it statistically good on the
cluster based annotation side I think a
very nice thing is to figure out a good
protocol for hierarchical sampling and
for this richer feedback if this is sort
of a sort of a new and growing area
right now and there's just a lot of
formalization needed on the graph and
also the cluster base annotation it
seems like you're you're labeling all
the data and needing this apply as an
actual classifier that might generalize
to new data that that isn't in your in
in the sent yet but it doesn't seem to
come from like a nice class of functions
the next function class is is this the
problem with generalizations so right so
both of these methods work best if if
there is some nice structure in the data
and it's not necessarily corresponding
to sort of a classical concept class
like a you know linear separator or
something but just you know some sort of
cluster structure this kind your
manifold structure and and so I think
it's a big interest just to formalize
some of these different types of
structure and then you know and see how
they answer saying that you think there
is an underlying function class that
they're following that should be
formalized or the
you should or you should enforce another
function class on it or you should not
worry about all right so I think that
you know for either of these two methods
there I don't think it's necessarily
useful to formalize a single function
class that they seem to be tailored
towards but rather to formalize a
variety of different types of structure
that they are adaptive to
[Applause]